ever notice how when you criticize a
white liberal they call you racist and
you think to yourself no no i'm
criticizing you the white liberal racist
[Music]
it's hilarious
but it's their first and last defense
hiding behind other people of other
ethnicities to push through their
preferred policies
and on no subject because it's more
obvious than immigration for years now
journalists have told us that hispanic
voters not they've met any love open
borders
and if you don't you're a racist
so all of a sudden there's some
cognitive dissonance going on because
hispanic voters actually don't seem to
love open borders and that's why in
overwhelmingly hispanic districts you're
seeing republicans getting elected who
are promising to enforce immigration law
so the new york times is extremely upset
about this they're trying to figure out
what exactly happened these voters
aren't as obedient as we thought they
would be they don't have the same
attitudes that we do here in
williamsburg like what the hell
and so they found a scapegoat they just
published an article with a headline
quote
the rise of the far right latina if i
write latino with that's our kind of
guest
one of those that they referred to is
cassie garcia who's running for congress
in texas and we are grateful that she's
joining us tonight
cassie garcia i don't know what a
far-right latina is but i'm
glad
it's a badge of honor the new york times
doesn't like you and we are very happy
to have you so now they're attacking you
because you don't have their views is
that what's happening
well tucker thank you for having me on
tonight it's just absolutely ridiculous
the fact that the liberal media would
call me a far-right latina because i
grew up in a conservative household on
the border and i went to church it's
just absolutely ridiculous yet they
praised aoc in the squad let me tell you
they don't represent our values in south
texas and the reason why i am running
for congress is to defend faith family
and freedom district 28 has been in
democrat control for 110 years and the
current incumbent henry cuer
who says all the right things has done
absolutely nothing nothing to secure a
southern border in fact i have received
the endorsement for the national border
patrol council who's always endorsed
henry clara but they've endorsed me in
this race for congressional district 28.
so i just think it's a little bit i mean
do you think it's weird that some
you know
white liberal from the upper west side
who went to brown and sends his kids to
riverdale country school gets to speak
for hispanic voters on the mexican
border in texas like where where do they
get the right to decide what you're
allowed to believe
you know what i'm i'm representing the
families and the communities of district
28 and they don't speak for me the new
york times um the democrat party has
left the hispanic community and in the
hispanic community we care about a
strong and secure border you know we
don't we don't want open borders at all
and that's what the democrat democrat
party it believes in and we don't
believe in that um we
believe in sovereign borders and so
that's why we're going to see more
democrats uh vote republican come this
november we're going to see more
democrats walk away
yeah i mean you're obviously an american
but i think even immigrants who just got
here of any background don't want open
borders why would you want to come to a
country that's not really a country of
course duh cassie garcia we are glad to
meet you so thank you for coming on
thank you thank you subscribe to the fox
news youtube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
tucker carlson tonight